[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on April the 5th
2023 my name is Freddie gray I'm the
deputy editor of The Spectator and I
will be your host today
first up on the show it is Holy Week and
we have a special Easter edition out but
we will start with uh the big story of
the week which is in fact The Passion of
the Donald Donald Trump has been
indicted in a court in Manhattan this
week to much International interest and
quite a lot of outcry and concern about
the state of Justice in American
democracy I'll be joined by the
journalist and broadcaster Megan Kelly
to talk about the political Fallout of
this historic and unprecedented event
and we will move on to talk about the
late Nigel Lawson who sadly died this
week he was as the spectator's leader
puts it this week the most consequential
Chancellor of our times I'll be joined
by Charles Moore a former spectator
editor and biographer of Margaret
Thatcher to discuss His Life and Legacy
after that we will talk about our cover
piece in the spectators Easter special
which is religiously themed
appropriately enough it's about Justin
Welby and Pope Francis and 10 years of
their divisive leaderships it's written
by Dan Hitchens the first of things
senior editor I'll be talking to him and
I'm also joined by the comedian and
broadcaster Andrew Doyle
and finally we'll be talking about art
in prison we have a very interesting
lead art review by Stuart Jeffries in
this week's magazine about a new and
rare exhibition of prison art by
prisoners in hmp Majesty's prison of
grendon
I'll be joined by Stuart and the poet
and prison Rehabilitation activist lady
Unchained
and finally a reminder that if you want
to subscribe to spectator TV if you
enjoyed this broadcast as I'm sure you
will you should subscribe to spectator
TV
and you can do that by clicking the
Subscribe button at the bottom of your
screen and there is a bell icon which I
have misleadingly said before this was
at the top of your screen it is not at
the top of your screen the Bell icon is
at the bottom of your screen so please
click on that to subscribe to The
Spectators TV channel
and while you're at it you may as well
subscribe to The Spectator it is the
greatest and oldest magazine in the
world you can do that at the moment with
a special offer which is for 12 pounds
you will get 12 editions of The
Spectator
as well as full access to the website
and our app and various other digital
offerings
to take advantage of that offer go to
www.spectator.co.uk forward slash TV
offer
so let's start with Donald Trump who has
been indicted this week after days and
weeks of anticipation and it's fair to
say it was something of a damp squib
I'm joined Now by Megan Kelly the uh
broadcaster and journalist and former
lawyer to talk about it um Megan I've
spoken to a few sort of get Trump type
people who've been determined to get
Trump uh for seven or eight years now
and they thought that in these 34 counts
um against Donald Trump there might be
something there might be some sort of
hidden thing that would actually prove
to be quite damning uh but I read the
indictment uh and I think it's fair to
say that it's um comically thin with
your legal brain on would you agree I
completely agree with you and I think
they're kidding themselves I think they
should be angry at Alvin Bragg because
there may be a decent case against Trump
at least more decent than this one in
the special prosecutor Jack Smith who's
looking into whether he openly defied a
subpoena that was served upon him and
Mar-A-Lago and had his lawyer say he
turned over everything when he hadn't
that one is at least interesting it is
colorable the this one's a joke it makes
a joke out of the justice system it's
absurd to violate nearly 250 years of
precedent and not going after former
presidents criminally with this are you
kidding me it's an embarrassment and
it's obviously an attempt to fulfill a
campaign Promise by Alvin Bragg who not
wants not twice but repeatedly over a
dozen times touted his record of getting
Trump of having been part of at least
100 lawsuits against the Trump
organization and the Trump family and
Donald Trump himself and promising he
was just the man to do it if they would
put him in office by the way the people
who were persuaded by that are Trump's
jurors that's his jury pool and his
potential jury which is one of the many
reasons why at a minimum this case
should be moved out of the borough of
Manhattan which went 87 for Joe Biden
but it is Finn gruel in that indictment
well there'll probably be a motion to
dismiss uh from from Trump's lawyers uh
I think the anticipation is that that
won't succeed do you think a motion to
move the the case out of New York would
succeed I don't think the motion to
change venue will be successful but I
actually don't feel as pessimistic about
the motion to dismiss as you do
um it would take a steel spine by the
judge because you get elected to the
position he's in the judges at the trial
court level in New York get elected and
he does not want to disappoint the
electorate by saying I threw out the
case against Donald Trump so it would
take a Steely spine but eventually it
could be it could go up an appeal and I
do think a an appellate court is very
likely to say this thing ought to go not
the immediate appellate court because
they're elected as well but the level
above that because there's no there
there if you look at it just in a
nutshell what he's done is charge a
misdemeanor crime which is falsification
of business records and the only way you
elevate that to a felony which he must
do because the statute of limitations
has run on those misdemeanors it was
only two years we're five years in he's
tried to elevate them to felonies so we
can get the five-year statute of
limitations by saying the reason you did
shenanigans on your bookkeeping was to
cover up an underlying crime now if
that's true he does get the longer
statute of limitations but we all waited
to say what's the underlying crime tell
us we're open-minded let's see what do
you do it's Trump he did something
we don't know yesterday Alvin Bragg
tried to play pin the tail on the felony
like we have no idea I don't have to
tell you he actually said but then went
on to say maybe it's federal election
law maybe it's state election law maybe
it's state tax law well let me tell you
something Freddie it is none of those
things because there is no federal
election law violation here
um I just got done interviewing the
former head of the Federal Election
Commission under Bill Clinton okay and
this person said it's very clear under
the best argument for Alvin Bragg that
this was not a federal election law
violation even if everything Alvin Bragg
alleges is true even if Donald Trump
David pecker of the National Enquirer
and Michael Cohen Trump's lawyer sat
down and said we have three potential
stories coming out about you how can we
get rid of them let's capture and kill
them here's a slush fund to pay off
these people even if true not an
election contribution that would have to
be reported and so on it's a personal
expense was paid from Donald Trump's
personal account and it just doesn't
qualify so there's no underlying crime
look at the state law the state law
doesn't have an independent area that we
can explore the state law just says if
you conspired to cover up unlawful
activity you violated New York state
election law that now we're back to the
federal law the only alleged unlawful
activity is under the federal election
law well I just covered that for you and
the New York state tax law there was no
tax violation what they're saying is you
paid off the women then you doubled the
number you paid and you added 60 Grand
and you paid that to Michael Cohen and
called it legal expenses why did you
double the payment because you wanted
Michael Cohen to not have to pay taxes
on the fees that he used to reimburse
Stormy Daniels and the others and take
the tax at himself so the Trump
organization took the hit but New York
State didn't take a tax hit nobody
didn't get paid their taxes in fact New
York State profited off of this money
scheme that they came up with there's no
damage and there's no fraud under the
tax law and even if there were were back
to misdemeanor territory so there is no
underlying felony or crime
um and and if we're going to go down
this line you know even further and say
okay I'm wrong about all of that uh
everything I just said is untrue and
Alvin Braggs won every motion they still
have to prove that Trump knew about it
and directed it and there's a lot of
evidence that he didn't that Michael
Cohen made this up because he absolutely
hates Donald Trump and all these
meetings he had with David pecker and so
on to thank him and which didn't have
anything to do with Stormy Daniels but
had to do with the fawning coverage The
National Enquirer was doing on Donald
Trump from the get-go
well New York state has had to pay a lot
in uh police fees and closing down roads
and so on in anticipation of an upsurge
of trumpist violence which didn't
materialize it does seem like a legal
nonsense and obviously a nonsense as far
as Justice is concerned should we talk
about the politics of it though
um because Trump has obviously had a
major boost in the polls uh as a result
of of this uh farce
Ron DeSantis is sort of a diminished
figure would you not say or slightly
knocked out the picture now and a lot of
people speculate that that's exactly
what the Democrats want and maybe this
is what it's all about it's an attempt
to make Donald Trump the nominee because
the Democrats think rightly or wrongly
that they can beat him
mm-hmm careful what you wish for uh they
tried that once before and he won in
2016. I mean we've seen this movie
before
um earned media coverage where the media
goes wall to wall Trump and no one else
can get any Oxygen
um the the candidate himself uh you
think he's going to be under attack and
uh seen as disgusting and somebody
nobody would want anything to do with
where in fact the American people see
him as persecuted and the victim of an
overreaching left and are impressed by
his fortitude and his strength and his
unwillingness to back down
um seeing his competitors have to
scramble in their messaging As Trump
takes up all the oxygen and dominates
with yet another Scandal the messaging
that doesn't alienate his core base and
the people who love him but
distinguishes you as a different kind of
candidate no one's been able to do it at
all in 16 and 20 or today and in 16 all
these same three things were happening
and we heard this is great there's no
chance Eagan women with all this going
on and we all know what happened well
it's happening again and people don't
learn they they don't learn Trump right
now is seen as Invincible they see him
defiant down there at Mar-A-Lago saying
you know I fight for you this is about
you it's not about me with the American
flags behind him looking strong looking
vibrant 76 years old but still looking
very energetic and they say he's the
only one who can fight these zealots
they wanted to pack the Supreme Court
they wanted to add extra States so they
could get rid of the filibuster in the
Senate they want open borders they want
all these they tried to absolutely
demolish Brett Kavanaugh when he was
nominated to the U.S Supreme Court with
totally scurrilous allegations you need
an extraordinary leader to take on these
fights and they don't see anybody
failing that bill besides Donald Trump
I can see yeah you're absolutely right
clearly that his his campaign has been
or his chances of winning the presidency
have been rejuvenated uh by this but is
there not a sort of longer term risk
that they're going to be more cases
we'll have the case in Georgia about
um that find me 12 000 ballots and so on
uh we'll have more about January 6th uh
and could Trump fatigue which has sort
of subsided a little bit uh in the last
few days could that come back do you
think as the sort of endless uh
allegation or allegation is is poured
out against him and people just sort of
tune off and feel fed up with I'm not
feeling that in this I mean it's
potentially true yes but the problem is
not one of these cases is sexy you know
it's not something that people can
easily connect with he had documents
that Mar-A-Lago that he is a president I
mean most of us feel like a former
president can take documents from the
White House and we're already told he
can declassify documents as the
president he says he did that with these
all right they're going to argue about
it well what's what did he really do
wrong because we know Joe Biden did it
too we know Mike Pence did it too
probably Barack Obama and others as well
what do you do you got an order to
produce them and he said he produced
everything when he had I mean it's
really hard to have your heart go a
flutter at that case it really is and
then the case in Georgia find me the
votes well if you look at the larger
conversation it's a lot more nuanced
than that he felt like he had the votes
and they were not counting them and he
was basically saying go count them for
him like I'm telling you uh this is the
number I need and they're there that's
what he's going to argue again can you
really get emotionally invested in this
one passing phrase in this much longer
conversation I don't I just don't think
people are going to connect with those
cases in any meaningful way and so they
can do 24 7 on this on CNN if they want
and people who already hate Trump will
watch it and feel gratified but I think
the Republican base which is what he
needs to get by first will be bored with
it might see that he's got baggage but
will also see this fighter who they need
to fight these extreme people who don't
can't even say what a woman is
um you know you need somebody who's
strong who knows how to fight battles
and craziness and I really think that it
will be more of a net benefit to Trump
than a net down inside
you mentioned Joe Biden uh it seems to
me that he's he's so far trying to act
as though he's above it uh sort of uh
his press secretary has sort of chewed
away questions about it as much as she
can uh do the Americans buy that or do
they see him as as part of the problem
that the Democrats are causing I think
he's checked out in many ways and people
understand that and he's obviously
partisan but it's yet another missed
opportunity for Joe Biden
this is a very dark day for America
yesterday whether you love Trump or hate
Trump
we've we've crossed it's a before and
moment it's a before and after a moment
for our country we there's a reason this
has never happened in nearly 250 years
and this no-name prosecutor out of New
York who's trying to become a star is
the one who decides he's going to change
all that he will Rue the day and so will
this country if you don't think the
Republicans are vindictive enough to to
turn the tables you haven't been paying
attention they will in the same way uh
they got rid of the filibuster on Lower
Court judges in the Senate and Mitch
McConnell stood up and said you will
ruin the day because you Democrats will
not only always hold control of this
chamber and when the Republicans got in
control they got rid of the filibuster
too only this time it was Supreme Court
nominees and guess what happened they
got three Supreme Court seats under
Donald Trump thanks to that the
turnabout if you don't think the
Republicans are going to turn this
around and use it against Democrats
you're crazy and if Donald Trump gets in
there you don't think he's going to
start going after people like Hillary
Clinton with his doj that's now under
his control it's it's a dark day so my
point is Joe Biden had a real moment as
the commander-in-chief as the leader of
the nation to come out and say
um this is a dark day for America the
legal process will play out as it should
and I trust in the legal process however
it is not lost on me that this is the
first in the American electorate's
history and my heart goes out to those
people who are hurting over it and I
want to reassure you that the backbone
of this country is strong and that while
we may have anomalies we may have
unusual events happen we're still strong
we're still at our core love each other
we still can get past red and blue he no
he didn't do it he smirked he smiled and
he declined comment it was a missed
opportunity and he looked foolish
he's actually coming to Ireland uh next
week he loves to play off his Irish
heritage you have Irish heritage am I
right insane I do I do my father was 100
Irish do you find uh Biden's Irish stick
of it bogus
well he's Irish and he's black and he's
Jewish and he's Puerto Rican I mean he's
he's claimed every Heritage Under the
Sun apart from English he never claims
that even though it's true right right
yeah so I find it a stretch
um you know here in America we've had
this round of people pretending they're
Native Americans when they're not and
they've become known as pretendians he's
that's what he's going to claim next so
I don't know hold your breath I'm not
sure about the Irish thing we'll find
out I'm sure and of course talking about
Republicans there's plenty of stuff on
the Biden family that they could go
after and they probably will
I I feel like it this guarantees it I
mean all you need is a state to
prosecutor I mean the feds aren't going
to do it because Biden controls them uh
Merrick Garland is his guy at the doj
and no federal prosecutor would do it
without his okay but the state
prosecutors I mean they're Republican
state prosecutors all over the country
including in States in which Hunter
Biden has had illegal weapons submitted
uh applications for those weapons which
appear to have had lies on them had
prostitutes had drugs on camera all
documented by the so-called laptop from
hell and that's not even to touch on his
nefarious business dealings uh and
what's gone on with the financial
alleged crimes there so the house is
investigating some of that right now
um and we'll see I he could definitely
be Target number one the clintons the
Clinton Foundation which has got all
sorts of red flags all over it uh when
it comes to their taxes and so on could
become uh the target of an investigation
down in Arkansas there could be a long
list and while it would be
further sadness for our country and what
we used to stand for it would be totally
fair
Megan it is indeed a sad day uh for
America but um it's Easter weekend
coming up so there's always hope I hope
you have a very happy Easter thank you
very much you too I'm looking forward to
it
now this week the conservative
Chancellor and former journalist Nigel
Lawson has died lots of senior
conservative politicians have been
um giving tributes to him and praising
his uh record in government and in in
the Press
um I'm joined by Charles Moore who is
like Nigel Dawson the former editor of
The Spectator
um Chelsea you've written this week
about uh well we can all talk about
Nigel Lawson's record as a Chancellor
and we should but you've written this
week about his um journalism because of
course he was editor of The Spectator
which is a much more important job than
anything else as we know
um uh what what was he like as editor of
spectator I appreciate he was editor
before you
um I think well Christopher files who's
still alive and worked with him
um describes him as positive cheerful
and dilatory and the final adjective is
slightly surprising but it's true
um Nigel rather like his son Dominic who
also entered the spectator is
um had a tendency to be late with copy
and sort of run right up to the wire in
fact maybe it's an occupational hazard
because Boris Johnson was also like that
um and um
in Nigel despite being very committed I
think probably all his
life to political Ambitions was a
genuine journalist if you see what I
mean rather than
um uh somebody who's also pretending to
be one because it's a useful thing to be
for a time
um and he had a very
strong journalistic feeling for what the
story was and
a desire to
um
expose things to public View and he
liked controversy and he liked the story
and
uh he wasn't frightened
um and I think he was a
excuse me I think he was a successful
um
editor that was in rather a bad hatch
for The Spectator in terms of finances
and so on and he had a certain sense of
Mischief or an eye for trouble as you
put it in the spectator this week he did
um he began Life as a city journalist uh
financial times and then the city editor
of the Sunday Telegraph when that people
began and um and I think he enjoyed um
sort of lifting the lid on things that
were going wrong with companies
um and he enjoyed lifting it on what was
going on with politics and
um journalists
are often unsuitable for politics but I
think he brought into politics a certain
um directness and
Readiness to address the story as it
were which is a on the whole of virtue
and politics and um and therefore the
way he
spoke and act it tended to
um
be closer to events it wasn't he was had
a highly strong intellect but it wasn't
a sort of um
it wasn't one that just sounded off it
was addressing what was really happening
and of course he was Chancellor under
Margaret Thatcher at a very important
time in in British politics uh could you
as Thatcher's biographer could you tell
us a little bit about the relationship
between them
well they were close in the early days
when he was very new in politics in the
1970s uh and she was in opposition and
he was doing some of the thinking um
particularly on the economic stuff and
by
1980-81 he he was confident enough to
give a major speech he was then a
treasury Minister about what thatcherism
was and he used that word and I think he
was probably the first
um conservative minister to use that
word intended to be used first of all I
think by her enemies such as Marxism
today
um uh and but he but he usually then he
justified it um and he
gave it to the perhaps a sort of
stronger economic theoretical basis than
she herself was likely to do and he then
became the architect really of a great
many economic reforms which were
uh thatcherite that were
important differences between the two
um and so the first for example which
actually came in when he was still only
a junior minister right at the beginning
was the abolition of exchange controls
which was
um absolutely vital in opening up
Britain for uh World investment and
World business
um and and then um he inherited from
from Jeffrey how the chancellor in the
first term
um a strong attempt to fight inflation
on which she built and he had been one
of the architect of the of the so-called
um
medium term Financial strategy which
explained the path that was intended for
get the money supply in order to set a
sort of pattern uh for the control of
inflation
um and then
um of course you get into high Thatcher
period when you're able to
uh uh defeat the trade unions
um and privatize
and also um introduce big bearing in the
city which meant that um
the traditional restrictions on um stock
broking and so on were were
largely jettisoned
and Banking and this allowed London to
recover its um remnants as a World's
Financial Center
um British sunac has also written a
tribute to Nigel Lawson in this week's
spectator
um it's interesting isn't it in terms of
where conservatism is now
um because you had all those victories
um under Thatcher uh and a a new
consensus
um a political realignment in favor of
free markets
um at that time and a lot of people
think that that is now under threat uh
do you think it is under thread
yes I think it is under a threat
actually because I think people don't
understand the creative opportunities in
free market so what they tend to think
is
this is just a way in which a few people
get rich quick
Lawson was perhaps the leading exponent
well this is actually very good too in a
different way about why this matters for
everybody not just why it matters for
people who are very actively engaged in
monetary transactions or whatever
um but in the whole of society because
um if you can increase competition and
remove restriction opportunities open up
for most citizens
um and it's part of a whole approach to
Freedom which is political as well as
economic it's it's about the whole of
your
uh and it's social it's about the whole
of your life and the possibilities in
your life and um
Lawson was good good at expressing this
Jeffrey how was more cautious uh Lawson
was better at expressing it in terms of
sort of optimism
and that was very true of the high
Thatcher period
yeah then um went wrong and this was
partly his fault uh actually because
he himself lost faith in his own
policies to control inflation
and he looked for a sort of alchemy
um to do so which was
um he thought to be found in entry to
the exchange rate mechanism the RM
which is actually wouldn't have it
because she could see it was leading to
a European single currency and would be
bad for the pound
um and so Nigel pursued it by secret
means by the circle shadowing of the
Deutsche Mark pegging in effect pegging
the pound sterling to the Deutsche Mark
and um when she discovered that she was
Furious
um
the Lawson boom had by this time got
definitely too big
um and um the ill feeling between the
two of them grew and this culminated in
um tremendous bus stop in which he and
Jeffrey how
asked to come and see her on a Sunday
morning in Downing Street and
gave her a sort of ultimatum that she
must agree to
into the RM
and this made it absolutely Furious um
it was known as the Madrid Ambush
because the relevant Summit was in
Madrid she got through the summit
without really giving them what they
wanted and sort of took her revenge
afterwards
but it wasn't a very happy Revenge
because
um the fact she'd fallen out with her
two
greatest ministers and and that this
concerned both Europe and economic
policy
was very it was something for which her
Administration never really recovered
uh he's also been called Boris Johnson I
think um referred to him as a father
figure of brexit uh I mean that is an
important part of his life is it not as
the Euro skepticism and the push to
drive the conservative party out of
Europe
yes what a rather complicated method is
when they're having this rabbit ERM that
he was not a Euro Enthusiast so that she
got into rather a muddle about what he
was up to because he agreed that there
shouldn't be The single currency but he
um he thought the RM would somehow avert
that it might have been the case of him
getting a bit too complicated
um he was always a Euro skeptic and he
became more so and when we got towards
the brexit referendum played an
important part
um
in all of that I I I'm quite sure that
he wasn't he didn't have such thoughts
when he was in office
but it's also the case that he was never
one of the great cheerleaders of the
European idea and he could very much see
the value of economic independence and
uh and of a separate currency for
Britain
um and that was a consistent thread
well a lot of uh critics of brexit think
that it the problem is is that lots of
journalists who tend to have a very slap
Dash approach to managing public life
have pushed us to this point and and
that's why we're we're not doing brexit
quite as well as we might be do you
think that's a fair criticism
not of Nigel Lawson
um
Lawson was billed but he wasn't slap
Dash he um he had a deep understanding
of economic issues and a very creative
mind
um and one that understood the
relationship between politics and
economics uh very very well
um he had a good technical grasp too so
he was actually very hard to fault on
all of that
um and I don't think he could be accused
of sort of carelessness
um he had a certain intellectual
arrogance and sometimes he thought
perhaps that he was just said he's a
he's brilliant but he's a gambler maybe
sometimes he was taking
too many risks because he thought he
could he was a bit of a magician that
there was he had the top hat and he knew
how to get the rabbit out of it
um and um
wasn't always absolutely true but I
think he was a
the most creative Steward of um
uh the British economy uh in post-war
era
um the most important and in many ways
the most successful
and finally Charles uh just because it's
one of my interests let's bring it back
to the spectator
when you became editor as a spectator
did you discuss
the editorship of this Magazine with him
not much because it was too long ago
really even then um he'd been out of it
for 15 years or something when I became
editor um but he used to talk about a
little times a bit he he liked his
journalistic friends he you know he was
um a pillar of the Garrick Club um he
was a keen
um connoisseur of newspapers magazines
um and he liked the somewhat refish
atmosphere he wasn't a natural
sort of departmental uh governmental man
in that sense he um he liked the fun of
it all and I think one thing he knew how
to do which was visible in budget
speeches and other initiatives was
uh journalistic presentation he knew how
to um
of course like a lot of people who've
been journalist he got very fed up with
with journalists and he
would criticize what he called teenage
scribblers
um possibly forgetting that he'd been
one
um but he um uh he he enjoyed it he used
to love coming to lunch at The Spectator
when he was Chancellor
um and
very open he loved like a proper
intellectual rather than a
pseudo-intellectual he loved discussion
um though he was very confident in his
own views he did want to hear other
people and he wanted to kick the
argument around so it was always most
stimulating you know
um
a couple of hours when Nigel Lawson were
never wasted
well Charles LED it there but thank you
very much for um talking to us about
Nigel Lawson
thank you thank you Freddie
now it is uh as we've already mentioned
Holy Week and uh the cover of The
Spectator speaks to that it's our Easter
special with some uh beautiful Easter
lilies there on it
uh and the lead piece
um is about the fact that it's been a
decade now
of
um Archbishop Welby being Archbishop of
Canterbury and Pope Francis being pope
of the Roman Catholic Church
um
I'm joined Now by Dan Hitchens uh who is
the senior editor of first things and
Andrew Doyle who is a writer comedian
and TV presenter for GB news and also
the author of this excellent book the
new Puritans how the religion of social
justice captured the Western World
um Dan you've written this piece about
well-be uh and Pope Francis
um and it's funny that they both became
uh leaders within days of each other
within eight days of each other I think
back in 2013 and when they were as you
say in the piece when they were
appointed when elevated uh they were
hailed as unifiers that might sort of
bring their churches together and in
fact as you spell out quite clearly the
opposite has happened has it not
it has and well to start with um Justin
Welby being Archbishop of Canterbury is
notoriously the worst job in the world
because there are such Stark divisions
within the Church of England
um that is remarkable just this year how
contentious those divisions have become
so in February the Church of England's
Parliament the general Synod voted to
introduce blessings for same-sex couples
which for many people looks like a step
towards an accommodation with same-sex
marriage obviously a very very divisive
issue and the uh Evangelical Council who
represent the very important Evangelical
wing of so they feel compelled to resist
this that if it goes ahead they'll
declare that it's contrary to the
scriptures about a serious Acclaim as
you could make
internationally as well you have other
Anglican leaders who aren't part of the
Church of England but recognize the
Church of England as their mother Church
who've issued a joint statement saying
we can no longer see the Church of
England as a mother church or or give
Justin Welby a sort of special
preeminence as the leader Among Us
leaders
and then as well as these big statements
there are multiple things happening at
the local level where you have churches
in London for instance two of the best
known big thriving churches have said
that you must suspend their standard
payments to the Diocese of London
because they feel so out of sorts with
their Bishop who supported this change
of a big church in Oxford which has said
the bishop can't come to receive
communion here or preach here so these
are remarkable steps it's not just
disagreement not even the kind of very
sharp arguments we've seen but something
very close to a Breaking of unity
um and you know as you mentioned in your
intro 10 years ago Justin Welby was
hailed as the man who could unite the
different factions he was a conservative
but he understood liberals and uh you
know if anyone could bring peace to the
situation it was him so that's really
the puzzle with which the piece starts
is how have we gone from
10 years of those very Rosy hopes to the
current extraordinarily divided
situation and just and just before we
get on to Pope Francis you do have this
bit in the piece where Welby has said
he's extremely joyfully celebratory
about same-sex blessings but he won't do
them himself which is a sort of amazing
bit of fence sitting is it not
yes and there was a a moment I think
last year where he said on the subject
of same-sex marriage more broadly uh
that he had a view but wouldn't express
it publicly
so this is his attempt to be a leader to
say you know I have to represent
um and speak to congregations with
vastly different views on this this is
my attempt to bring them together it was
a good encapsulation of his approach
before he became Archbishop just before
when he was asked
um you know you have people who think
that having women Bishops is completely
impossible
within the Anglican Faith you have some
people who think it's absolutely
necessary otherwise we're not real
Christians how do you square the circle
and he said oh it's very simple it's a
circle with some sharp bits on it
which is a really good sound bite but
it's also sort of saying I don't know
how to make a statement that I think is
true and that applies to this situation
maybe we can ride it out and he hasn't
been able to to write it out even with
his diplomatic and and communicatory
skills
and let's just uh quickly sum up uh the
problems with in Pope Francis
pontificate
um I mean he is uh he's seen as divisive
because he seems to pick fights with
almost everyone uh within the Catholic
Church does he not hmm
yes I think there's something even more
fundamental which is that uh catalytics
have enormous respect for the pope as a
teacher whose words carry enormous
weight and Pope Francis will make
statements which are extremely confusing
on really quite fundamental matters he
issued a document which was partly about
uh very serious questions about marriage
about the Eucharist the central
sacrament of the Christian Life
and it was very unclear what he was
getting at and some senior Cardinals
wrote him said could you clarify these
points
um and he didn't acknowledge the request
or he didn't want to meet them didn't
want to address it and they've been
probably dozens of examples where he's
acted in that way where people sort of
Look to Him for spiritual guidance and
he comes up with thoughts that could be
interrupted in any number of ways
um and I think there have also been
episodes where he's intervened in
communities particularly recently with
this Crackdown on the Latin Mass
um where basically it's now a lot harder
for communities who want to have the
Liturgy in that form to have it uh which
have deepened those those divisions once
again 10 years ago an enormous wave of
Hope a lot of press about uh how Pope
Francis could get Beyond these silly
divisions between Christians and get
down to what really mattered uh and it
turns out it's not that simple that
there's something much more serious in
these divisions than perhaps almost
anyone had understood at the time and I
think certainly these two leaders had
understood because that's been the story
of their leadership is it gradually
emerging
how contentious these issues is how
difficult it is to bring sides together
Andrew I'll bring you it let me wave
your book around you wrote this book the
new Puritans uh how the religions of
social justice captured the Western
world are you surprised to the extent to
which religion as in Europe's religion
Christianity main religion Christianity
uh has itself been captured by social
justice
this is one of the most surprising
things I mean we've all become very
accustomed to this new ideological
movement infecting any institution it
touches whether that's in uh the media
or the corporate world or the even the
Judiciary or the police or or the NHS
we've seen how it works it infects
everything it gets into the surprise has
been how readily uh it has been able to
unveil its way into a traditional
Christian movements I even spoke to an
Evangelical preacher from America from a
Baptist Community who's who was talking
about how uh various of his colleagues
are now um running sessions on
intersectional readings of the Bible so
even the most sort of uh fervent
traditionalist movements or branches of
Christianity don't seem to be immune uh
to this particular movement and I think
this is why it is kind of unprecedented
I mean Dan makes the very good point
that it's always been the case uh that
there has been a struggle between
conservative wings of various churches
and the more Progressive wings of
various churches and that's particularly
in the Anglican church because of course
uh various particularly in Africa a lot
of the Bishops in Africa are inherently
traditionalists and want to promote that
idea and are now considering obviously a
Schism and it's always been the case
with Catholicism as well but I think
what is new and what is different is
that this particular ideological
movement is by its nature intolerant I
mean Dan says in his article that
progressivism has a religious fervor of
its own but I would add to that that
this is a this is especially the case
when you have a regressive movement that
Styles itself as Progressive but is
nothing of the sort and that is what
we're dealing with here it isn't the
sort of movement that will Brook dissent
so in terms of squaring the circle I
don't think it's I don't think it's
actually possible I think it has to be
one or the other and do you think I mean
the religion of social justice is is
intolerant as you say and do you think
that's where it gets its strength from
and that's why to a certain extent if
there is a battle for Souls going on
it's winning
it will win because it's scary because
you know it's practitioners have
developed this thing which we
colloquially call Council culture what
that really means is bullying what it
means is if you don't subscribe to our
views we'll ruin your life and they can
be very scary people
um so of course you end up with this
situation where the Archbishop Academy
is having to sort of please everyone
because it's absolutely terrifying to go
up against these kinds of activists who
have got made their way into the
Anglican Church as well
um I in terms of the Pope I suppose he
has a uh a slightly different situation
but at every successive Pope whenever
they contradict something a previous one
has said is in trouble because of the
notion of people infallibility so often
it comes down to fudging of the language
which is why you get this idea of
squaring a circle as as Dan has pointed
out
um but this the the movement is
impossible to resist in that respect
unless you are courageous unless you are
able to say no we have certain beliefs
that are not compatible with your world
view and remember that this ideology is
a movement that really is about the
negative nation of reality the negation
of of Truth uh it has all the Hallmarks
of a religion of its own you know it has
its own esoteric language it has its own
foundational holy texts such as those by
the likes of Judith Butler and Michelle
Foucault
um so you can't just expect it it
doesn't it doesn't blend well with other
institutions it takes them over it works
more like a virus and in that sense
um the the various churches the Catholic
church and the Anglican Church could
well do with it with a kind of
inoculation rather than this attempt to
fudge it and attempt to bring it in and
claim that it's compatible it absolutely
is not
well Dan as Andrew suggests that isn't
it a quite a big opportunity for the
Christian churches uh it to resist uh
the religion of social justice because
as you as you say in your piece you know
that the elements of Christianity that
thriving tend to be conservative ones
and and young people tend to be drawn
towards uh more conservative forms of
Christianity
um probably or possibly because uh it
offers an antidote to to this negation
of reality to this sort of uh total
post-modernism
um when it comes to Truth uh that
they're offered everywhere else
is definitely the story of our times the
divisions are sharpening in politics and
in fundamental questions like
what is the difference between men and
women uh on which
you know it's very hard to claim that
people will try to claim
um that you know the Christian tradition
can be reconciled with what is now
increasingly the fashionable view so I
think
that is um uh that is one area where you
can see uh that trying to unify
progressivism and Christianity is
probably not going to work there has to
be a confrontation at some point
um and as you say people who've grown up
uh in the last 30 years are quite likely
to recognize that and I think that's why
you find it is often the younger
believers who are more conservative sort
of which can seem paradoxical to people
who remember the 60s but someone like
Kate Forbes the SMP Leisure Canada as
was who got in trouble for her views on
same-sex marriage and premarital sex and
so on you know 33 years old she's in
some ways quite representative that
younger generation of levers who are
kind of unembarrassed know where they
stand and definitely stand with a more
traditional conservative View and you
mentioned this fascinating these of
Richard Rex the Cambridge historian who
says there's three reformations the
first was what is God the second is what
is church and the one we're living
through at the moment is what is man or
I suppose what is woman uh might be the
the current question uh how is that how
does that apply to to what you're
talking about in terms of well-being and
Francis
back to what I was saying but in 2013
very few people realized how big this
crisis was there was a sense of well
we're Christians we all believe that God
is love uh we all believe in helping the
poor we all want to be United
um maybe we can put on aside these uh
kind of arguments which aren't that
essential about sexuality and gender and
so on
um but actually those arguments are
about human nature and this is the
Richard Rex analysis you mentioned that
the history of Christianity has three
big crises in it one about the nature of
God when you have
um you know mobs storming uh the
churches of Bishops trying to
assassinate them because they've got the
wrong view on how many persons there are
in the Trinity the Reformation obviously
another big crisis over the nature of
the church
and we're now living through an upheaval
which is as big as those and could go on
for as long which is about what is it to
be a human being basically and we're a
long way from resolving that question or
resolving these these debates so I don't
think we should expect any Unity anytime
soon but Andrew where there is possible
uni where there are possible unities uh
is between strands of liberalism that
have for decades been viciously opposed
to to Christian teaching and seeing
Christianity as very backwards and
regressive and uh let's say
um the Christian churches I mean there's
uh there's Mary Harrington something
like that is an interesting writer who
writes about reactionary feminism and
that actually a lot of uh liberals who
are kind of being mugged by wokery as it
were are now
um finding forming alliances with with
Christians and with Christian thinking
on ideas of Truth and so on
well yes because we often forget that
the Christian churches in our
contemporary time have been liberalized
rather successfully I mean long gone are
the days where the the Catholic Church
taught that if you were you were gay you
should be burnt at the stake and you are
essentially evil and demonic you know in
the catechism it talks about yes it's an
intrinsic moral disorder but it is not
the case that someone who is inherently
attracted to members of their own sex is
evil that is accepted amongst Catholic
teaching as being a a state of nature
something that is part of their being it
is the act uh and of course the the
Catholic church has always taught that
any sex act outside of wedlock is sinful
anyway so it isn't a kind of anti-gay
thing and the church has liberalized and
attitudes have changed but what you have
now is a movement that sort of seizes
the mantle of liberalism and claims to
be Progressive and it's nothing of the
kind it's actually closer akin to the
kind of uh intolerant uh elements of
church teaching that the church has
moved Beyond and is Left Behind
um so that's where you're going to get
this this conflict fundamentally uh
modern day Christianity has at its heart
the notion of forgiveness and repentance
ideas which are completely alien to the
Contemporary religion of social justice
those are things that they don't believe
in they believe in uh cruelty and
viciousness as a means to coerce people
and to go along along with their world
view I cannot see how that could
possibly sit side by side with Christian
teaching plus the fact as you've
mentioned so many young people are
coming up and are attracted to the
traditionalism of the church that was
the whole appeal of of the both the
Church of England and the Catholic
church is it's rooted in Tradition and
and that is something that is going to
appeal more and more to young people are
going to react against I mean let's not
forget that the religion of social
justice is largely propagated by people
of my age uh by um Millennials and and
Gen X uh these people are old now
Millennials you know they're in their
40s right so younger people are going to
react against it and then you've also
got the the the the the
insurpassable obstacle I think that some
of the teachings of the religion of
social justice are just fund mentally at
odds with Christian teachings
particularly when it comes to gender
when the when you have this idea there
is a gendered soul that we all have that
is at odds with our body that cannot uh
possibly uh sit with Biblical teaching
it doesn't make any sense it's
incoherent and so I come back to this
point I just think
reconciliation is impossible uh the
conflict you mentioned is coming uh and
it can't come too soon
and dad I mean I used to work at the
Catholic Herald which you edited
um uh and we used to do quite a little
stories on the humanism that's coming
together of anglicanism with Catholicism
to Bringing together the two churches
that's not really on anyone's priorities
at the moment within Christianity is it
because both the animal communion and
the Catholic Church are so busily
fighting each other
true to some extent but I think all the
things we're talking about mean you know
people discovering new enemies they also
discover new friendships so I do expect
to see more conversations and perhaps
more kind of unlikely alliances and
interesting agreements between
um uh Catholics and anglicans who you
know agree about the nature of marriage
even if they have
um very fundamental disagreements about
um you know other questions that the
Eucharist or the nature of authority in
the church and I think those
conversations are starting to happen so
this is yet another example of the
upheaval uh that we're living through
and that's got a long way to run the app
well Dan and Andrew I think we'll end it
there but a very happy Easter to both of
you
[Music]
now let's talk about art in prison uh we
have a fascinating piece the Arts lead
in this week's Magazine on a exhibition
I think it's the only exhibition in the
country of prison art at Her Majesty's
president grendon
um the piece was written by Stuart
Jeffries who joins me now he's an author
and spectator contributor and I'm also
delighted to be joined uh down the line
by Lady Unchained who is a poet and the
creative director of Unchained poetry
which works with prisoners and doing
poetry uh I'll start with you
um and your excellent piece
um tell us a little bit about this
exhibition exhibition uh you know what
were your impressions of it
um how's it come about and all that well
it's come about because
um grendon is a really unusual prison
it's it's a therapeutic prison it's the
only one in the country that was like
that that's been set up to do that with
the aim of debilitating quite serious
offenders yes such as category BS is
still quite seriously yeah yeah so if
you actually go to the site and
buckinghamshire there's a beautiful
stately home which is an open prison and
then next to it is grendon which is
fenced off quite quite harshly all
people in there 200 men thereabouts have
applied to be at grendon because it's to
do with therapy and to do with their
Rehabilitation they're all trying to get
parole trying to get out there a lot of
them are coming to the end of quite
serious sentences so one of the guys I
met was a murderer who who uh been
convicted when he was 15. now 18 years
on he's up for parole and he's one of
the people who's taking part in this art
project and the art project is really
strange it's in a singular in that in in
prison there's lots of drama therapy
there's lots of art therapy this is
slightly different in that they're being
taught to produce Contemporary Art
they've been given skills in
etching and photography and drawing and
things like that by artists professional
artists who've come in one of whom is a
is an artist in Residence who's been
there for four years
um he hasn't really in Residence
actually because he can't stay there
overnight but you know the the whole
thing is it's a very very unusual and
for them it's it's about trying to learn
artistic skills and also getting really
absorbed in art in a way that they
wouldn't have done in in in any other
any other prison really it's a really
unusual in any way quite moving but also
a place but also raises lots of
interesting questions about you know how
serious are we about rehabilitating
artists how would I have felt if I found
out that some of the Arts I'd seen on
the walls this Gallery was Say by I
don't know Gary Glitter or by you know
murderer all the I saw was was you know
Anonymous yes I think your piece is very
good on that that you know we're
obsessed with counseling people and so
on yeah and when it comes to Art uh you
know for centuries people have been able
to draw a distinction between the
artists and the art and actually you
know quite often very terrible people
have done some of the greatest art uh
going yeah uh and and prison art sort of
forces us to confront that yeah it's
that's quite a very interesting subject
yeah I mean imagine if
you know has never been convicted of
rape but a lot I don't know there is
this Council culture a mood around his
work you know one should not exhibit his
films it's great films and they are
really great if however you know he
might produce some art anonymously while
in a prison like this would it have been
okay you know would it would you know
you think it were terrible should it be
exhibited and there seems to be this
kind of straight really strange attitude
towards prisoners and towards
Rehabilitation yes should we allow it
you know yes do we believe in it in
ourselves you know yes lady unchanged
um tell us a little bit about Unchained
poetry
um and also I'd like to talk about uh
you know sort of funding for art therapy
in prisons because uh if we accept that
it's an important part of Rehabilitation
and I think most people do
um is it significantly underfunded I
know that this this exhibition Stuart
was was funded is funded charitably
isn't it yes that's right yeah yeah
um so tell us a little bit about that
please
yeah uh Sunshine poetry is an artistic
platform that I created for artists with
lived experience at the criminal justice
system so that is artists that want to
do poetry spoken word rap song you know
any form of like a performance element I
give them a platform and a stage to do
so
um in regards to
um creative work and activities within
prison 100
underfunded I think a lot of
organizations that work with our
Charities and they are basically you
know jumping through hoops just to get
this money in order to be able to
deliver and facilitate workshops that we
know is so beneficial for the people in
prison that you know when you're in
those sessions you see somebody that may
have never ever expressed theirselves in
their whole childhood life up to adult
life all of a sudden you give them a few
lines and you give them a pen and a
paper and they start to express some
things that they have never shared
outside of their home outside of their
friendship circles and I think with art
it gives people the power to understand
their Journey not just their crime alone
what led up to that cram how you know
what was you thinking what was you
feeling who was you with before that
time when you start to write especially
through poetry or spoken word it gives
people a moment I don't tell people that
we're going to do therapy because no one
wants to you know no one gets excited
for therapy but once you're in the
session it is a therapeutic kind of
experience and a lot of the times I get
young people say to me oh you think
you're clever you had us writing for
like three hours you know it's they're
not understanding that you know they are
writing but because they're enjoying it
and expressing themselves in a in a
space that to be honest prison is a dark
place it's a lonely place and in those
two hours you give somebody just a
little view of what could possibly
happen outside of that door and for any
viewers who are thinking this sounds a
bit like sort of bleeding heart
liberalism there's a very good
conservative argument for it which is
that you stop reoffending rates uh which
are far more expensive for the
government or you reduce reoffending
rates which which is makes sense on a
number of levels doesn't it
exactly a lot of the time we know this
well fact that half half of the people
released from prison within a year go
back to offending or commit another
crime outside of the crime they did if
we had you know these amazing creative
spaces in prison why can't we continue
that on the outside so that they have
somewhere to continue growing as an
artist and a lot of the times people in
prison didn't even know they didn't even
know they were artists just like me I
never believed I was a poet when I
picked up a pen it wasn't to become a
spoken word artist it was just a time
for me to get over those emotions get
over the anger of being in prison but
also the darkness and pain that God
follows with that sentence so for a lot
of people once they discover that
there's no Outlet on the outside so they
tend to go back to old ways you know old
Outlets instead of kind of re-channeling
that pen and that notebook well is it
that I mean a lot of people who are in
prison uh came from uh dysfunctional
families or you know did not get the
education that children need to have and
so prison sort of fills in uh the Gap
where which schooling left out
I mean I think what's what's sad about
that is the fact that a lot of the young
people we've got young people coming
straight from the care system straight
into secure units from secure units into
Crews from poos into young offending
prisons it's a journey and a lot of the
young people that I've met once they
were kicked out of school and you know
it's sad for me to say this but I have
to say it I had a group of eight to ten
eight to ten boys and all of them said
to me if they had never been sent to
approve they would not know half of the
gang members they know today so clearly
we are sending them somewhere that is
only allowing them to have access to
more people that are committing more
crimes and bigger crimes so my thing is
education especially through lockdown we
say that it's so important for people to
have education especially young people
but during lockdown there was no
education that means all prisons
especially young offenders were not
getting education for those two years
there was nothing happening that means
that we're looking them up and somehow
hoping that by sitting behind the door
they're going to learn all the things
that they need to learn in order for
them to come out and be a normal
civilian in the outside world which
unfortunately isn't happening yes we had
a fascinating piece in The Spectator
recently by Charlie Taylor who's Chief
Inspector of Prisons about the
devastating impact of lockdown in
prisons and things like literacy uh
Stuart you've probably come across this
too literacy rates among prisons are
very low prison is often a very good
chance to improve that that hasn't been
happening generally enough anyway and it
certainly didn't happen during lockdown
when prisoners were effectively and feel
free to come on come in on the stage
Unchained
um prisons were effectively just just
shut in in solitary confinement for
large a lot of the prisons I talked to
said during lockdown they were you know
they're out for an hour maybe and their
classes were canceled and they were
really miserable because it gives them
not just creativity but it gives them a
sense of absorption in that almost like
D.H Lawrence sense of when you're
absorbed in something that's really
inspiring to you it's liberal writing
and freedom freeing as well as equipping
you with kind of skills that might be
useful to you on the outside world you
know so yeah lockdown's really hard for
a lot of these guys a lot of these I
don't know you know I'm you know I'm
outside the criminal well clearly but
I'm trying to understand what what it's
like to to have got into the criminal
system and what it must do to you is
quite a worthwhile journey to do and
it's a lot of the guys in there were
very well qualified you know some of
them have done degrees in criminology
and had come from very very humble
backgrounds very vulnerable backgrounds
you know sort of parents who are heroin
addicted and all kinds of terrible you
know things in their upbringing and were
very had been you know very inarticulate
pre-literate and had done a job on
themselves and made themselves over so
anyway prison's a terrible place to be
particularly because of what lady young
chain was saying but it's also a place
where you can have an existential
breakthrough and change yourself and
that's something I'd have thought you
know it was worth encouraging otherwise
what are we doing we're just holding
people in in a prison where they're like
to reoffend and you know that's not good
for anybody Le'Veon you mentioned that
uh prison is a very weird place
um you're an ex-convict yourself could
you give us a sense of just how weird it
is
you know prison is a very weird Dark
Lonely place and people would think but
there's thousands of people in prisons
it doesn't make it doesn't mean that
it's a comfortable place and you know
there's a lot of the time people say oh
you hear that people are playing games
or you know they're doing artistic stuff
and they should be punished well
actually don't we want the people that
are in prison to actually better
themselves while they're in there isn't
that the pain the whole process of
prisons in order to make somebody you
know Channel their their feelings and
understand why they commit crimes in
prison unfortunately this Rehabilitation
word for somebody that has been behind
the door I learned Rehabilitation
through picking up a pen I learned
Rehabilitation through the other women I
met in prison there was no guideline of
how to do that so for me prison is a
weird place because I felt like I was
sent there to learn something but I
wasn't taught that I taught that through
myself through my writing and through
other women that thank God saw something
in me and decided that they will kind of
teach me or show me how to do things or
make sure that I know how to you know
get an app in prison is a weird place
because this word Rehabilitation doesn't
exist in prison it only happens through
creative arts through Charities that go
in there through the amazing power of
national prison radio to be able to host
shows into prisons every single day so
that people actually have an outlet or
understand that there is people outside
that are still listening still fighting
and still willing to help them share
their story and actually help their
voices be heard
well that is very interesting indeed
thank you very much lady Unchained and
thank you Stuart for joining us both on
spectator TV
that is it for the week in 60 minutes
you are now free to go from your
incarceration for 60 minutes we hope
that you have enjoyed what we've put on
the show this week
I would like to remind you before you go
once more that you should subscribe to
our YouTube channel and to do that you
click the button at the bottom of the
screen and also the Bell to get a
reminder whenever there's a new episode
and finally once again do subscribe to
The Spectator magazine and take
advantage of our brilliant offer which
is 12 editions of The Spectator and full
digital access for just 12 pounds
you can take up that offer by going to
spectator.co.uk forward slash TV offer I
really think you should and as if that
wasn't enough we will throw in a 20
pound Amazon voucher for everyone taking
that offer up
thanks again for watching I wish you all
a very happy Easter and don't forget to
tune in again next week
[Music]
thank you